goodmorning reject nation and good
afternoon India this is Greg
I'm John we are going to watch the
Spider Man into the spider-verse
trailer numero dos today I'm excited for
this movie almost as excited I am for
before we do that I just want to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us over at our patreon and
we're gonna use all the money
contributed to the patreon to stop all
that noise going on outside
hey the city not to do whatever they're
doing now yes because they don't realize
sometimes trailers drop very early in
the morning and this is the most
important thing that could be happening
at this hour of the day Oprah at our
patreon we do weekly Q&A s which are a
total blast and we also do TV show
reactions for many it shows the ones
that we are currently covering attack on
Titan my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham Riverdale
and supernatural so once you go check us
out see if you like to become a patron
Jack today might be worth your time it's
certainly worth jobs let's do it what
makes you spider-man
seeing that to a lot of other spider-man
hey spider-man - Ram swings in once a
day stopping his little mask and answers
to no one
[Music]
dad I love you
[Music]
[Laughter]
just in time for fall
[Music]
[Music]
today
to the loo
[Music]
is what makes you spider
you guys might not know this or do you
really know this sometimes with John and
I haven't read the source material that
comics are inspired from we often do a
lot of research to you know pick up on
as much as we can and then you're left
with that feeling of it's only borrowing
from the source material the main thing
it's borrowing is there's a spider verse
and there's multiple spider we're gonna
borrow morales is the main spider-man
yeah maybe you know some of the sequels
will have like a whole army of spider
yeah and have like those weird vampire
villainous spider-man I keep hoping all
of these common universes get to is I
want to see like the weird offshoot I
mean they've got the pig one I forget
was that that spider a big spider pigs
not spider pig that that's the Simpson
spider pig spider pig does whatever a
spider pig spider-ham pepperidge it they
included spider-ham just because it
seems like a very Lord and Miller thing
to do Nic Cage is spider-man you are
yeah you got spider going over here
which Nick Cage is getting a superhero
on this year because it was like
Superman and Teen Titans go and now he's
spider-man over here you know he's red
Mandy
it's crazy evil I'm kind of thinking
that maybe in the finale Phil Lord and
Chris Miller who who worked on the
script for this and produced it I
imagine that you know kind of thinking
of 22 Jump Street ending that were
probably even the finale we're gonna
just get like oh yeah snapshots are like
mock-up comic book covers of all the do
Spider Men that are kicking ass at
different combinations I just bring them
into the finale but keeping its focused
on these main six spider-man mm-hmm
spider-man spider-man
of course Miles Morales being the main
one and Peter Parker be the main
supporting one yes which I really like
that concept but kind of a hammy off
what's funny is the opening of this had
seem to have two references Akula
reference issues because even though
Tobey Maguire is obviously not voicing
who's Jake Johnson a Johnson yeah you
know you had the upside-down kiss you
had the Train moment and then you also
had he's that dinner and the car comes
in yeah then he punches it hey man no
that's not how it goes down spider-man 2
but it's a direct reference to
spider-man 2 when he's when he's having
lunch with would Mary Jane and then Doc
Ock there's a car which personally I
just appreciate cuz I got a real soft
spot in my heart for those original two
spider-man movies right there well I'm
kind of wondering is this spider-man
that spider-man it seems like that's
what they're suggesting and if that's
what they're suggesting then my dream of
there being a Nemo Peter moment come
true
does that mean spider-man 3 is also can
yeah I mean that's pretty cool to me
though if they were to do that I'd be
pretty satisfied with that well I wonder
I mean not that it's a big deal
but I wonder if maybe they'll make some
other cheeky references to that side of
the spider-man universe because like by
doing this they kind of have access to
everything
yeah the amazing spider-man can
theoretically fit in here if they want
to do and I mean we talked about the
animation every time we've talked about
this movie but this trailer even takes
that one step further for me like
there's some amazing looking just
sequences that really remind me of just
splashing a comic book across the screen
firstly for real you know hey guys
everyone amber was spider-gwen looks
pretty cool too man I mean last time we
only got a tease of her and seeing her
in action you know is about it remind me
a Ruby Rose it's what I kept thinking
there's plenty of other moments there
that I'm really much looking forward to
I mean you got kingpin in here who I've
always wanted to see brought to the big
screen maybe he will smash a guy's head
in here just to give it that our rating
the Venom's not giving us oh ya gotta
get those references got to get those
references all the bloody Romans
absolutely you're looking for and you do
see you know photo and Mary Jane maybe
she'll make a cameo in here you also get
an image of the Prowler you know Aaron
Davis we've touched on before itsy
goblin at one point and you also have an
A and look throwing down bout to kick
smash just like Marisa Tomei just a
little bit hotter here looking like
Jamie Lee Curtis in Halloween right now
absolutely I think at the end is that
Ned I feel like there might be Ned I
mean III get looks like he you know
maybe lost a little way you know maybe
been working out but I mean it looks
like it could be Ned for sure a similar
gag to the one in Spiderman home which I
would not put it past Lord Miller to
recreate in some way and also he's a
spider-man comic I like that
Mehta today we're gonna give a patient a
day shoutout to a man named Niraj
Krishnan Niraj my friend the one who's
always on the lookout for the next
hottest greatest trailer ever tonight
and you and I we're gonna do a google
hangout soon buddy I'm excited for that
why because we will finally get to see
your face on camera for the first time
and be able to verify for ourselves that
you're like a real-life Peter Parker I
mean you got the glasses you got the
unassuming demeanor but I think deep
down probably you're harboring some kind
of pain and rage you're gonna take out
in the streets maybe take out on a few
low-level thugs you know to realize that
your life's on the wrong path you want
to shape up and really walk the path
justice and you know New York pizzas
good I always say take out your rage on
your loved ones so no Raj you go ahead
and do that this Tuesday afternoon buddy
because that's what you need most we
love you and we'll be talking with you
soon guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell cuz you know that's what we all say
now and check us out on patreon there's
stuff bye